hi my name is Patrick Muldoon and I'm
playing Lynn Jones the one and only lint
Jones Punk legend so your character is
in recovery or has just come out of a 90
day I just made it 90 days towards my
recovery and I've given up crack and
cocaine for red vines that is the
creator of Lynn Jones so how much does
how much of Patrick is in Lynn Jones and
how much does he not unfortunately quite
a bit really like what parts the music
part I've been a musician my whole life
and acting's always paid the bills but
you know music is is my love and you
know who incidentally the the owner of
this house she does even the band
sleeping masses and I go yeah I go how'd
you know she goes because we when she
was working at Universal put some of the
music in some of the shows so anyway so
to this point an unrecognized musician
and unlike Lindt who really had his time
in the Sun as a punk rock God and you
know who tried his best tried his best
at two failed marriages he's got three
kids one kid has a restraining order
against him played by shannen doherty
and I haven't done those things but I
can't wait for that a lot of chaos in in
in Lynch life but this this time out of
rehab which is about time number 10 he's
really going to try because
you know this time when he cleaned up he
realized that he's at a time
how much similarity do you see between
the musician temperament and the actor
temperament I'm very different very
different yeah how so you know there's
there with actors it's uh you don't get
together for fun and read lines you know
you don't get to get together for a
fight hey what are you doing this
weekend you know let's read a play
together but musicians it's hey dude you
know we're gonna be down it you know
whatever rehearsal hall down here in the
valley and and we're gonna jam and so so
this I'm not saying that musicians
aren't competitive they are but it's
more about the creation of the content
of the song it's about the song so
everybody loves to get together to make
music acting it's bit competitive and
there is maybe I don't know do you think
there's more narcissism and acting than
there is a music or it's there's plenty
of narcissism in any field to go around
but yeah you know I mean I'm not
slamming actors because but we are self
employed it is you are the the product
so you have to take care of yourself
make sure you're taken care of and and
so it's yeah it's it's a bit spit
different coursers narcissism and music
if you're lucky enough to I'm very
humble in music because I am NOT a rock
star at the moment but when you get what
see old adage you could tell who
somebody is not when they're at the
bottom but when they're on the top and
they have the the free will to do to
actually act and that's when you're at
the top you see how somebody treats
people that's who they are and Lynn
Jones evidently didn't didn't treat
people very well because he's got to
make amends while he's eating red vines
and so you
this is the man right here Dean I know
he's a hip-hop portion of our show he's
your sponsor right Punk cause we're my
sponsor we're gonna make a new kind of
music punk punk punk aah
so he's trying to you call him in
moments of weakness he's my sponsor I
just got out of the 90-day program so
you know you choose your sponsor and I
chose d-major and why is hilarious
Sheldon's great why does your character
choose someone that's maybe turned his
life over and I think he's a vegan and
he's more like all-natural where's your
still smoking what is it that attracts
well it was probably the probably the
music thing you know the music thing I
mean you have to deal with you have to
deal with it with specific things that
the normal cat doesn't really have to
deal with you know so that's why you
have certain celebrity groups of AAA and
certain performer you know musician AAA
you know actors a because because
they're specifically you just have to
kind of deal with different things that
come with the territory and different
temptations that come with the disease
sure you know on tour away from your
wife away from your kids it's easy - Wow
I'll just I'll just turn it up this one
this one time you know with the boys on
the bus or in you know some put up put
up town somewhere so there's a lot of
temptation because there's a lot of
access you have access to everything you
want so so lint has failed and the but
the beautiful thing about what he's
going through is with sobriety comes
authentic emotions you know you can
mentally try to change your life all you
want but if he and you can't do it alone
so like D major he has people around him
pulling for him and then but most of the
people he has to go earn it again hey
pull for me on this last
try and he really thinks is his last try
does Linton have trust issues does Lin
have trust issues yeah yeah he's manager
you know see old stories manager took
his money his manager took his
publishing he was on drugs his yeah his
riders and publishing have all been
somebody else owns them probably would
be a great time for Lin to write music
at the crossroads but it's that's what
that's what I like where he is he's
having authentic feelings for the first
time like a teenager what he's in
adolescence right cuz he never
progressed he never progressed he never
had to it was stunted yeah and it makes
you think you know you think of people
that you know the famous rock and
rollers who died Jim Morrison
Kurt Cobain you know at 27 years old
what did you know at 27 years old I was
a punk kid in 27 years old
to have that kind of responsibility you
know Shawn and you could see how we
could how we could do people in so this
is this story of somebody who was at the
top and maybe some of the classics who
unfortunately passed away the Sid
Vicious is and Darby crashes had they
lived what would their families be like
how many families would they have had
were where their children where is he
when the fame goes and when the fame
comes back and his relationship to his
addiction so do you think part of Lin's
problem was self sabotage I think he
felt like yeah deserve any of it self
sabotage for sure who thinks they
deserve it when there aren't you know I
it takes a real somebody with real
internal structure at a young age to be
able to handle thing and you can just
open up your tabloid magazine it's all
over the place not when you have access
to everything to really have the
internal structure some people do really
seem to do it really well I can't think
of one right now but well maybe they're
sober and that's the thing for Linda's
he okay with in writing music
when he's sober because somebody come no
you you have to you have to get used to
having sex over you have to get used to
having to riding sober when you're in a
position like Lent and so but the
discovery of that is funny it's funny so
this is a dark comedy about something
really human but the the emotions are
really potent and you have to go deal
with mom who you've been lying to for
years but she's but and then damage do
you know you damaged your mother and you
have to walk crawl in the door you know
and ask for another chance each wife you
know one of the character that Joey
Fischer plays is Debbie who's really
somebody who probably authentically
loved him although they hooked up in the
bathroom at the whiskey you know so she
was a fangirl so who who knows you know
from where little it's coming from and
were people in this situation in life
famous famous people how do you trust
who loves you and who doesn't
you know when were you presented with
the script
let's presented with the script three
weeks before three weeks before how a
game did my manager called me I think
James our director is the one who
brought me up pitched me the producers
and hey Larry said call me lint man I'm
in character
I'll be right there anything more you
want to say we'll wrap it up Larry sorry
right now okay
you